i often have this strange thought that
aliens come down to earth to check us
out
they beam up 100 scientists and they ask
them what's going on on your planet
and the aliens quickly learn something
that all of these scientists have
concluded
that pollution from our industrial
activity is irreversibly heating the
earth
in a way that'll make it very hard for
us to live here safely
then they do the same thing but this
time they beam up another 100 people and
they're not scientists the regular
people like us
they could count on one hand how many of
those people
would even mention climate change two or
three dozen of them may never have even
heard the term
and among the americans in the group
only one in four would be highly
concerned about the issue
the aliens i think would be shocked why
don't people know what's happening
or how bad it is someone should tell
them the absurdity of this situation is
so clear
and so real what we have here is a
failure to communicate
my job is to educate people about
climate change so i look at the concepts
the messages the images and the terms
and i test them with millions of people
i'd like to tell you what i'm learning
for so many people climate change seems
abstract
distant too big to imagine the words we
often use to describe it
emissions co2 methane net zero
anthropogenic are simply put confusing
not that many people wake up in the
morning and say it's a great day for
some decarbonization
these words become obstacles rather than
gateways to understanding
let alone caring the way to fix this
failure to communicate
is to start not by talking about the
issue but to start with people
to think first about individuals the
people who have millions of other things
on their mind
a million worries and challenges and
hopes and aspirations
climate change is one of the biggest
threats humanity has ever faced
and we won't face it not to the degree
that's necessary
if people don't care the people first
approach to climate communications
demands three simple things
the first one is plane obvious and
universal language
one thing for sure people don't readily
get carbon emissions
net zero or most terms that can be found
in the science book
and frankly to the uninitiated much of
it doesn't really sound that bad
2 degrees warmer in 50 years or it
sounds so bad you can't even get your
head around it
1.2 trillion tons of ice confusion and
hopelessness are the enemies
of understanding a good test for
language is what pops into your head
when you hear it
if you hear a term like climate change
what pops into your head well for most
people the answer is
not much the language isn't vivid what
we need is vivid language that everyone
gets
it's remarkable how many people actually
confuse climate change with the ozone
hole
more than four in 10 americans think the
ozone hole actually causes global
warming
and so many of them remember and
understand so much about ozone depletion
why is that because it's a hole it's a
layer
people can see it imagine it relate to
it it uses simple metaphor
that's an instant get here's a little
story that gets a similar aha
for climate change humans have been on
earth for about 300
000 years but we've only started
polluting like this in about the last
60.
our pollution stays in the air for
thousands of years creating a thickening
blanket that traps heat in the
atmosphere
that heat causes stronger hurricanes
bigger fires
more frequent floods and the extinction
of thousands of species
but there's good news to stop the
pollution blanket we just have to stop
polluting
this pollution blanket framing is one of
the most effective we've tested
at getting people to understand the
issue it's visual it's vivid
and when people hear the message they
become significantly more engaged
they get it there are so many other
regular speak words and concepts that
stick with people
instead of warming try overheating
instead of climate talk about extreme
weather when mentioning clean energy
you might say cheap energy as well as
it's rapidly becoming cheap
the word irreversible really gets
people's attention as the pollution
certainly is
and if you absolutely must talk about
temperature increases and you live in
the u.s
heck use fahrenheit for goodness sake it
doubles the severity
nine degrees during your kid's lifetime
sounds pretty serious 1.5 degrees
celsius to meet the paris accord
is pretty ignorable this is about going
beyond arcane policy language
into language that we all intuitively
get that's the first step
understanding but understanding without
relevance is rudderless
so the second key then is to make
climate feel like something that matters
to you
to your life individually and personally
nobody has an epiphany about policy
proposals awakenings are personal they
have local relevance they're about your
life and your concerns
as an example we presented two messages
to a few thousand people in florida
one asked them to demand that we get to
zero emissions to stop climate change
another simply said stop my flooding the
latter message was over four times more
effective in getting their attention
local flooding was so much more relevant
than global warming
what's needed isn't better policy
descriptions but rather deeper
more personal connections here's another
example we work with a team of
remarkable women climate scientists
to help elevate their voice as
messengers they've dedicated their
careers to studying the issue
developing complex computational models
to understand the arctic processes
and climbing into planes to measure
nitrogen in wildfire smoke
they could tell you everything you need
to know about the science but what we
asked them about was why they study it
and they told us about their daughters
and their sons about wanting to keep the
world safe
and healthy and vibrant for their
children and when we shared these
personal stories with other parents
they started to care far more deeply
about climate change than they did from
staring at charts of global temperatures
people see a parent who's dedicated
their life to creating a better world
for their child every parent can relate
to that it matters to me
the right messages are those that
connect climate change to personal
identity
our life not future lives not the world
our community not necessarily
environmentalism our values
and not just children our child finally
the third key to the climate
communications puzzle
to show that climate change is an issue
for people like me
humans are social animals and that's
true for how we form our beliefs too
you can present the exact same message
to many people but when it comes from
someone with a similar accent or
background
we see double-digit increases in message
effectiveness
here's an unexpected messenger who
really lands the point a guy we call
florida man
he's a resident of north florida who got
into a little trouble with the law after
taking an alligator into a convenience
store when he was on a beer run
not exactly the most obvious climate
change messenger yet when he appeared in
an internet ad describing in his own way
how he's worried about his way of life
it significantly increased climate
concern
among young conservative men in florida
most people don't see
themselves as environmentalists per se
and they see climate change as an
environmentalist issue
but messages that break away from those
narrow identity markers
make the issue relatable they give
people a reason to care
so the core idea is that instead of
explaining the issue at people
it's essentially to bring people into
the issue so that they say
i get it it matters to me it matters to
people like me
then and only then are we primed to take
action if the intelligent aliens in my
story were also intelligent at
communications
they would say to us hey earthlings pay
attention
you're building up a massive blanket of
pollution that's overheating your home
and it's going to hurt the people and
the things that you love
you did this and you can fix it we
simply have to let our fellow 8 billion
inhabitants of our home know
what's happening we have no choice and
when we do
we'll achieve the public will necessary
to take on this colossal
but winnable fight for our future
thank you